we usually think of rhythm as an element
of music but it's actually found
everywhere in the world around us from
the ocean tides to our own heartbeats
rhythm is essentially an event repeating
regularly over time even the ticking of
a clock itself is a sort of rhythm but
for musical rhythm a steady string of
repeating single beats is not enough for
that we need at least one opposing beat
with a different sound which can be the
unstressed offbeat or the accented
backbeat there are several ways to make
these beats distinct whether by using
high and low drums or long and short
beats which ends up being heard as the
main beat is not a precise rule but like
the famous Rubin's vase can be reversed
depending on cultural perception in
standard notation rhythm is indicated on
a musical bar line but there are other
ways remember that ticking clock just as
its round face can trace the linear
passage of time the flow of rhythm can
be traced in a circle the continuity of
a wheel can be a more intuitive way to
visualize rhythm than a linear score
that requires moving back and forth
along the page we can mark the beats at
different positions around a circle
using blue dots for main beats orange
ones for off beats and white dots for
secondary beats here is a basic two beat
rhythm with a main beat and an opposing
off beat or a three beat rhythm with a
main beat and off beat and a secondary
beat and the spaces between each beat
can be divided into further sub beats
using multiples of either 2 or 3
layering multiple patterns using
concentric wheels lets us create more
complex rhythms for example we can
combine a basic to beat rhythm with off
beats to get a four beat system this is
the recognizable backbone of many genres
popular around the world from rock
in country and jazz to reggae and cumbia
or we can combine a to beat rhythm with
a three beat one eliminating the extra
main beat and rotating the inner wheel
leaves us with a rhythm whose underlying
feel is three four this is the basis of
the music of whirling dervishes as well
as a broad range of Latin American
rhythms such as Coral
and even Bach's famous chuckle now if we
remember Rubin's vase and here the
offbeat's as the main beads this will
give us a 6/8 feel as found in genres
such as choco data and cueca
in an eight beat system we have three
layered circles each rhythm played by a
different instrument we can then add an
outermost layer consisting of an
additive rhythmic component reinforcing
the main beat and increasing accuracy
now let's remove everything except for
this combined rhythm and the basic to
beat on top this rhythmic configuration
is found as the Cuban it's sinking in
the Puerto Rican bomba and in northern
Romanian music
and rotating the outer circle 90 degrees
counterclockwise gives us a pattern
often found in Middle Eastern music as
well as Brazilian Shortell and
Argentinian tango in all of these
examples the underlying rhythm
reinforces the basic one too but in
different ways depending on arrangement
and cultural context so it turns out
that the wheel method is more than just
a nifty way of visualizing complex
rhythms by freeing us from the tyranny
of the bar line we can visualize rhythm
in terms of time and a simple turn of
the wheel can take us on a musical
journey around the world
you